hey what's up guys mkbhd here and every
single year there are two main phones
that really help us to shape our vision
of the future of smartphones that really
help us out and that is the iPhone the
new iPhone every year comes out and the
Nexus so there's going to be a future
video about the new iPhone so stay tuned
for that if you want to see that but for
this video we're going to talk about the
new Nexus the Android flagship coming
later this year so first of all Android
7.0 nougat is already out there I've
been running the beta on my Nexus 6p for
a while and there's also now the new
Nexus launcher that you can install on
any phone if you want that's been out
there for a little while - I've been
using it and I'm pretty much used to it
so the launcher still has an app drawer
but it's no longer an app button you
swipe it up from the bottom row of apps
and then you have a search bar for all
your apps at the top and a vertically
scrolling list so that's sort of a new
swipe gesture there it also has a new
folder design which I didn't like at
first but it's minor so I've already
gotten used to it and then it shrunk the
Google search bar that's usually
permanently at the top to just a
permanent letter G up in the top
left-hand corner and then you can see it
puts the date on the top right-hand
corner but I wish I could click the date
like just to get to the calendar but
maybe that's coming soon there's also a
new wallpaper picker which looks pretty
sweet and now there's also these
features are starting to trickle down
into third-party launchers so like go
launcher or a nova launcher if you're
using those then you can sort of try one
or two of these features at a time
instead of going with the whole Nexus
launcher experience right away
I'll leave the apk that I use to install
the Nexus launcher on my phone right
below that like button if you want to
try the whole thing but again if you
don't then you can just grab like nova
launcher and try a couple features we're
also expecting a few new features to get
added to the final version of android
7.0 before it gets launched with the new
nexuses at the end of the year one of
these being like right now when you long
press the home button you get to Google
now on tap the new Nexus is expected to
launch with a fancy new animation where
if you long press that you'll launch
into a more full-fledged Google
assistant so that's the software side
and that's exciting everything but what
I'm most excited about is the new
hardware the new Nexus phones launching
this year and I did say Nexus phones
because we're expecting two new nexuses
again now we got last year Nexus 6p from
Huawei and Nexus 5x from LG a really
high-end Nexus phone and then this sort
of a mid-range lower price phone we're
expecting to see the same sort of
strategy again this year two new Nexus
phones one high-end one mid-range both
built by HTC so this is the Android
police mock-up of what the next Nexus
will look like both of them actually
there's one will be smaller one will be
larger but they'll both have this same
design but yeah based off of all the
information and leaks that they've
gotten this is the representative model
of what it should look like so right off
the bat that dual tone design is a
little bit head-turning obviously so
it's a mostly metal body all the way
around but then a really big glass
window to allow for things like NFC and
GPS and maybe wireless charging if it's
tall enough not sure we'll have to see
but also I'm feeling it's going to look
a lot better in real life than it does
in these mock-up renders I mean if you
remember the Nexus 6p when we first got
the renders and the leaks of seeing this
phone for the first time it looked like
the hump on the back was going to be
huge and ugly and people hated it before
it even came out but then we got the
phone in real life and it's more of this
slender glass window same idea here the
other things you'll notice are there's
no camera bump nice and there are also
no front-facing speakers sadly it's a
dying breed but overall it's a pretty
simple looking phone no groundbreaking
crazy-looking features or anything like
that and then the specs so here's the
specs of the smaller Nexus all right
quad-core chip 4 gigabytes of RAM looks
pretty good 5-inch 1080p AMOLED display
so AMOLED again nice to see in a smaller
phone and a 2770 milliamp hour battery
32 gigs of storage I hope that's the
base model hopefully no 16 gig version a
12 megapixel camera on the back and 8
megapixel camera on the front and a
fingerprint reader USB type-c port down
facing speaker and a headphone jack up
top and the larger higher-end nexus will
be again quad-core Qualcomm chip 4
gigabytes of RAM not six but that's fine
5.5 inch quad HD AMOLED display same as
Nexus 6p nice at 3450 milliamp hour
battery again good to see 32 or 128
gigabytes of store
age okay and another 12 megapixel camera
on the back eight megapixel camera on
the front fingerprint reader USB type-c
port downward facing speaker and a
headphone jack up top side note I do
think it's ridiculous that we have to
mention a headphone jack as a feature in
a phone that's the second phone this
year that's how to do that Juwan know
what else it comes with an audio jack
I'm just saying we also have this EV
league's tweet that shows that Verizon
may carry these nexuses for the first
time in a long time last time Verizon
carried a nexus was like that actually
one of my favorite phones ever the
Galaxy Nexus and they had their weird
ways with that phone and they screwed it
up in their own little ways but also
verizon likes to rebrand a lot of their
phones they make droid editions out of
everything so he put Nexus in quotes as
if they may rename it and rebrand it
either way I'm still gonna buy the
unlocked version so overall all this
info is really good to have what it's
really telling me is that these two
phones are probably going to be very
similar to each other both have the same
design they'll both be made by the same
manufacturer that didn't happen last
year so HTC will make both and they may
actually have the same exact camera
modules again which did happen last year
and that was pretty good for the
mid-range phone to have a high-end
camera but I think we're gonna have to
wait and see for that and also I feel
like we're gonna see a lot more emphasis
on the Google assistant part of it at
the announcement so the long press on
the home button with the fancy animation
to get to a little bit more than Google
now on tap that's going to be a big
focus in my head anyway we'll have to
wait to see I got to give a shout out to
Android police because 99.5% of the new
info we have on these nexuses is because
of their digging and their hard work so
shout out to that I'll link what they do
below and also have more smaller stuff
like the camera app is going to get
manual exposure back and the fingerprint
reader will have a swipe down gesture to
bring down your notification shade and
the new version of Android stuff like
that so we have it let the Nexus hype
begin I'm pretty excited let me know
which of the phones you're more excited
for a lot of people were really psyched
about the Nexus 5x last year I'm
personally a big phone type of guy so
I'm excited for the higher-end phone but
most of this is just we shall see so
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one
please